appelé le mouvement populaire à se
rassembler autour du parti socialiste
pour sauver et imposer les objectifs de
l'union de la gauche
il me semble que cela aide de musan
contenu compris par l'électorat oui vous
craignez pas que le pilonnage du parti
communiste vous pose des problèmes
naturellement les deuxième tour des
présidentielles du roman il nous en
pause si le parti qui si les dirigeants
des partis choristes val l'échec de la
gauche comme cela semble aujourd'hui
démontrée bien entendu ils peuvent le
faire
j'ai déjà dit une fois je me répète très
la victoire dépend du parti socialiste
mais la défaite de porte du parti
communiste alors je voudrais pas plus de
notre entretien s'achève là et d'être
humains il est très heureux 27 déjà
monsieur oui oui ils vont nous allons
jusqu'à 13 heures 34 tenir et moins
encore à parler sport
cgg vous en a parlé avec david et bonce
permettez j'aimerais dire que limité
alors rien dire avant la fin de
l'émission je partageais mitterrand
parce que moi j'avais plein de notes en
venant dans l'autre nation non je
n'aurai pas le temps je le sais déjà que
j'ai pas le temps
j'ai juste le temps me mettre en colère
quand j'ai commencé avec l'en non c'est
le système de l'information française
qui fait comme ça j'aurai le temps une
minute de m'énerver juste de m'énerver
de paraître pour un petit merdeux un
petit jeune de la pagaille partout
je préfère m'en aller tout de suite si
j'avais su comment dire j'aurais dormi
beaucoup plus tard dix ans souhaitait
votre présence l'allée balavoine danse
leur studio pour parler des problèmes de
la jeunesse je pense que nous
thor 2 orioli temps d'en parler c'était
vraiment pas de chance y aura les uns
des autres et c'était pas de chansons
dont il était question je vous en parler
pendant 10 minutes au moins de la sphère
georges marchais dont tout le monde se
fout strictement je vous signale que la
jeunesse française se font strictement
de ce que monsieur marché faisait
pendant la guerre ça lui est
complètement égal ces intérêts seraient
plus la jeunesse de savoir ce qui se
passe et comment le parti communiste en
caisse de l'argent pour le dépenser
après notamment la mairie de bagnolet
ses intérêts seraient mieux de savoir
comment gaston defferre dirige sa mairie
socialiste qui n'est pas un modèle de
société à marseille s'intéresserait plus
de savoir les jeunes français comment
monsieur raymond barre qui est arrivé il
ya cinq ans ou quatre ans je sais plus
combien temps a dit que les salaires ne
seraient pas diminué mais qu'à augmenter
les cotisations de sécurité sociale
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant que tout
ce que vous racontez georges marchais on
s'en fout de georges marchais il faut le
savoir de ce qu'il faisait pendant la
guerre ça nous est complètement égal le
problème de drogue de la façon dont on
le traite les ministres français on s'en
fout il n'y a jamais un jeune ministre
delà de la jeunesse en france il y en a
jamais c'est tous des vieux
regardez monsieur soissons enfin vous
n'allez pas me dire que c'est un homme
représentatif de la jeunesse regarder
comment je suis habillé ils sont plus
souvent biais com - les jeunes que comme
monsieur soissons il faut quand même pas
rêver tout ça ce sont des métiers j'ai
encore pris plein de notes au fur et à
mesure que vous parlez ce que voudrait
savoir ce qu'ils meurent intéressé c'est
de savoir à qui les travailleurs
immigrés payent des loyers qui paye
on a vu tout à l'heure des gens qui
désirent on paye 700 francs par mois je
voudrais savoir qu'ils encaissent de
l'argent pour louer des poubelles pareil
c'est ça que je voudrais qu'on me dise
c'est pas de savoir comment on peut
faire pour changer jeu murray qui ose
tous les mois demandés 700 francs à des
travailleurs immigrés pour vivre dans
des poubelles dans des taudis
ça c'est ça que je voudrais qu'on
m'explique pas ce que moi je ne le sais
pas c'est pas la force de la formation
qui me dit je voudrais savoir pourquoi
monsieur boulin était suicidé ou s'est
suicidé ou on ne le saura jamais
pourquoi monsieur fontanes hérité ce
signe est pourquoi la sphère le brüggli
n'a jamais été éclairés pourquoi le juge
renaud on s'est pas ni pourquoi ni
comment il a été assassiné
j'en ai d'autres la seule chose que je
peux vous dire monsieur mitterrand je
m'enfuis de vous avoir parce que je suis
fier d'être là je peux vous le dire on
s'en aperçoit peut-être pas mais vous
pouvez pas imaginer ce que c'est pour un
jeune d'avoir la possibilité de parler
une minute c'est pour ça que j'avais
peur de ne pas pouvoir parler parce que
ça n'arrive jamais faut bien se mettre
ça en tête
ça n'arrête jamais regardé l'émission
qui a eu hier soir sur antenne 2 les
dossiers de l'écran
enfin vous n'allez pas me dire que les
mômes qui étaient concernés par la
contre attaque
j'ai abandonné c'est vraiment la chance
il on est obligé vous et vous exagérez
l'information je suis obligé de
l'hexagone pour résumer je la résume à
ma manière que j'essaie de lire
rapidement mes notes
ce que je vous donnais en tout cas c'est
généralement c'est un avertissement j'ai
peut-être du culot de faire ça je suis
obligé de le faire comme ça parce que je
dois faire vite
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse désespère elle est profonde et
profondément désespéré parce qu'elle n'a
plus d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française
et moi je pense qu est la règle générale
résume en un peu bien raison ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que le désespoir et
mobilisateur et que lorsqu'il devient
mobilisateur il est dangereux et que ça
entraîne le terrorisme la bande à baader
et des choses comme ça et ça il faut que
les grandes personnes qui dirigent le
monde soit prévenu que les jeunes vont
finir par virer du mauvais côté parce
qu'ils n'auront plus d'autre solution
voilà je vous remercie d'avoir laisser
parler le semis qui en voulaient des
lieux dialoguer avec un jeune vous
l'avez écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
ce qui ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est
que cette façon de penser de réa j ai
aussi s'exprimer parce qu'en face daniel
balavoine s'exprime par les cris par la
musique ait droit de cité
puis ses 30 ans du et donc puisse être
comprise le dit à sa manière il est
responsable de ces paroles c c'est un
citoyen comme un autre mais typique et
quand je dis typique c'est parce qu'ils
représentent à mon sens des centaines de
milliers de jeunes conditions de vie ou
dans quelle banlieue
quel logement quels loisirs entrant dans
une société bétonnées qui se ferment
partout de vente avec le chômage pour
perspective pense que quelqu'un qui sait
dire et chanter c'est à dire exprimer
sous la forme de l'art drame vécu de
cette force devait être entendue lors
d'une émission de se chambrer pourquoi
condamner balaban parle
il rejette l'information c'est un autre
problème mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils
rejettent tous les hommes politiques
qu'ils soient de droite ou même s'il a
le droit
et pourquoi pas moi il a le droit moi je
suis pour que tout soit dit et pour que
tout homme politique puisse être remise
en question ça m'arrive tous les jours
et si cela devait arriver avec daniel
balavoine bien j'écouterai quand même ce
qu'il a à me dire
bon alors voilà pourquoi cela ne doit
pas nous amener deuxième incident de
séance au fond de cette émission a germé
comme il était 13h 30 points vous avez
dixneuf devenir à 34 ans j'ai gagné le
gazon n'a pas encore dans les unissent
et passionné sur le football sait pas
comment vous dire daniel brême que l'on
ne peut pas résumer la politique
française avec à des conflits d'ailleurs
provoquer artificiellement par le parti
communiste entre georges marchais moi
avoue rené andré je suis sûr que telle
était votre intention
au nom donc je ne voulais plus pas mais
simplement nul ici nous nous adressons à
des millions de gens qui ont besoin de
savoir qu'on n'ait pas pu parler encore
du 1,9 pour cent d'augmentation des prix
au mois de janvier d un million cinq
cent mille chômeurs
aujourd'hui dès 9 milliards de déficit
du commerce extérieur sur les deux
premiers mois de l'année soit presque
autant que toute l'année dernier qu'on
n'ait pas pu parler de la situation des
épargnants qui vont peut-être voir
augmenter de 6 et demi pour cent à 7 %
la rémunération de leur épargne
tandis que la spéculation conduit par
exemple et les grandes sociétés qui
peuvent emprunter les grandes sociétés
peuvent emprunter à 20% aux etats-unis
d'amérique et la dévaluation de fait du
franc c'était la dernière réussite de
monsieur bah dévaluation de fait en face
d'un dollar à 440 et d'un marquage de
francs 40 ans alors je veux dire kenya
nous allons et à lumières quand même il
ya quand même deux politiques il faut
faire le choix à celle que je dénonce et
il ya celles qui est contenue dans le
projet socialiste tient pas d'autres
voilà pourquoi je leur ai dit même si on
n'en a pas laissé beaucoup de la bible